on Weibo which is often been dubbed
China's Twitter news of George Floyd's
killing and the protests we're trending
with these hashtags while Londo en the
Chinese version of tik-tok videos like
this were being widely shared many of
these videos were created by accounts on
two widely viewed platforms the chinese
state media publication people's daily
and television networks CCTV the actual
violence that has sparked up this
movement Biddle's today the aftermath
the looting the rioting has been
catching the attention of chinese state
media in part to show that you know the
protests in the united states particular
peaceful at a time when global backlash
builds against china / coronavirus and
Beijing's relationship with the US grows
increasingly strained China's cover-up
of the Wuhan virus allowed the disease
to spread all over the world events like
the protests and the pandemic have given
the Chinese propaganda machine a lot to
work with here's a look at the narrative
that's being crafted and why rallying
citizens at home is critical to
Beijing's power though the
demonstrations in the u.s. have been
largely peaceful inside China the
protests have mainly been portrayed like
this
some of it assists Buganda but some of
it is just reporting the actual news
shows to the Chinese public that's the
u.s. far from perfect
maria rep nicola is a political
scientist who studies Chinese propaganda
it's just a really kind of huge amount
of information that's coming from the US
media scale on the protest movement into
the Chinese domestic media sphere so
it's been really impressive to worship
replicas versus state media often choose
the most violent scenes use dramatic
music
and often feature president Trump and I
will deploy the United States military I
hope that you also use our National
Guard call me to use military force
those movements
I can open without whose region
dimension do typical night yung-chun
meeting yeah booths achieve a the come
from Godwin Lincoln so in June the Trump
administration placed restrictions on
Chinese media organizations including
CCTV and people's daily calling them
members of the propaganda apparatus
Rudnick ovis says the u.s. protests have
also come at an opportune time for
Beijing in the early stages of the
pandemic as hospitals became overwhelmed
and there was little information about
the new virus Beijing turned to a
trusted strategy suppress any critical
news coverage people knew in advance
about all the risks and he an impacted
nature of the virus so the question
about why early warning center dr. foo
quinoa has been tracking sensor posts on
Weibo since December 2019 by scanning
more than 11 million posts that
mentioned coronavirus related words he
says Chinese censors covered up negative
reports from vloggers to a whistleblower
doctor Chinese authorities have made no
public statement about the vloggers
whereabouts while the government praised
the whistleblower dr. Li wen Liang as a
caring and committed doctor after his
death from kovat 19 meanwhile state
media content about China's prompt
response like to hospitals that were
built in under two weeks or Premier's
Lika Chang's visit to Wuhan circulated
widely on wave
do you through research found that
around 2 out of 1000 posts related to
the outbreak on Weibo were censored the
streets large amount of votes so they
basically occupy the my quality of not
censorship spike during key events like
the death of the whistleblower dr. Liang
Liang or when the CDC published a paper
confirming human-to-human transmission
which sparked an online debate about
whether the government knew earlier many
reports have also featured foreigners
saying positive things about China
[Music]
president countries to share its own
shorty die self it's similar to today
but she did while gauging real sentiment
in China's state controlled online
environment is difficult some of the
comments under these posts show
Beijing's narrative appears to be
convincing to some social media users
and it's appearances that matter says
Rep no Cova because this type of
nationalism is the point of propaganda
and one way for China to secure its
legitimacy at home as tensions outside
the mainland increase
[Music]
you